i came across the short story while i
was editing weekend and I did kind of
see this as like a bookend kind of story
really I do see them very kind of
similar in many ways I think one is
about two people trying to understand
their identity and who they are through
the beginnings of a relationship and
this one is about obviously a long-term
relationship and how people can
understand who they are what they want
from a long-term relationship and how
kind of fragile both those things can be
the beginning of something and the
possible end of something um now the
actors in this movie my gosh I mean
you've never worked with actors quite of
this caliber in stature before I'm
talking about Tom and Charlotte of
course how did you get those two
involved was it just a case of them
seeing her previous film and wanting to
work with you or was it the script that
drew them into the project it was kind
of it was a lot of begging basically I
finished the script and I don't write
with people in mind because you just
never know if you're going to get them
and it's just to kind of I don't know
terrifying to write with people in mind
in case you're going to be disappointed
when they say no so we finished the
script and I sent it to resend it to
charlotte very quickly it was always our
intention to cast the female lead first
obviously because you know she is very
much front and center of the film it's
her perspective and I didn't even want
to think about who would go alongside
him until the female role had been cast
so I sent it to Charlotte and I send
copy of weekend and I said and skipped
and a letter just you know saying why I
wanted her to do it and how wonderful I
thought she was and then we did it hand
written no it was type that's bad that's
okay I should handwriting future and and
then I was in LA I was editing and she
just called me up and I was in the hotel
and she was like hey it's Charlotte
Rampling here and also go God and we had
long conversation for like an hour and a
half just talking about you know what I
want it to be and what she wanted it to
be and then at the end of the
conversation he said yes and she said
she'd love to do it and then I studied
kind of talking with her about who I
thought would be good as the male lead
and Tom was one of the people that we
both would be fantastic for it because
he has kind of certain qualities I think
as an actor that some of those like men
of that generation don't have he has
like a real kind of sensitivity and the
kind of vulnerability
and I think a lot of those older actors
don't necessarily possess that and I
think Tom doesn't that kind of made
sense to me within this relationship so
we sent it to Tom I sent him weekend he
didn't watch weekend he still hasn't
watched it refuses to watch it he
started it and he said I can't
understand what anyone saying they're
just like mumbling and I don't
understand what it is with young actors
and they were there mumbling they don't
mumble they do a little bit a little bit
but you know he's from the theater he
like he likes a bit of a nun see asian
and they at Tom said yes as well and
then you know that was eerily it was
like we had them both on board the thing
that I find so fascinating about the
film I've interviewed before about the
picture is that the fact that that you
don't do a rehearsal process and these
two had actually never worked together
on screen before they once appeared in
the same film together i forget the name
of that film do ya and night in Lisbon
with nine lesbin yeah they were in that
together but they didn't share any
scenes together I totally bought them as
a couple that have been together for 45
years otherwise your film obviously
wouldn't have worked how do they go
about fostering that relationship well I
think to start with it as good actors so
I think they knew that going into it you
know they had to make the audience
believe that they liked each other and
that their relationship had had gone
into that kind of comfortable zone
relationships I think go into after a
while you know but we didn't rehearse
because i don't like rehearsing i find
it I don't know why it doesn't do
anything for me and I'd like the
spontaneity that you get in the moment
and Charlotte doesn't rehearse either
she's like I'm not rehearsing so don't
ask me so I didn't ask her sure Tom
loves to though because Tom loves it
he's a huge believer in rehearsal so I
think it was a bit harder for him
because we were because there was no
rehearsal time but what i did was i
spent like three days with charlotte and
then three days of tom and we just
talked about everything like my process
you know directing is usually you know
about the stuff you do before you get to
set well then what you do on set so it
was about just us all understanding what
it is we're trying to do what it is we
want everything to say what want the
character to be and then once you get to
that stage it's quite not i would say
simple but you've done the hard work and
then we turn up on set I think we had
one morning when we read through this
it and they had like a cup of coffee the
two of them together by themselves and
that was it yeah but we you know it was
a very small intimate crew and they
lived in like a little hotel with their
like rooms backing up against each other
and they were just the only people in
this hotel the two of them so they you
know got friendly very very quickly but
it's also just chemistry is something
that comes from good acting and the
right you know story I suppose that
makes sense and you also shot this film
chronologically so that no doubt helped
with that what went into that choice did
you shoot weekend chronologically mean
obviously I'm looking you can't do that
I try to shoot everything even looking
like when we can when people allow me to
I will try and always shoot it in order
and lots of a DS get furious with me
because obviously it's complicated and
this film was complicated to shoot in
order because you like you upstairs in a
bedroom and normally you would do all of
those scenes together but I'm like no
click go downstairs now we've got a it's
got to be nighttime now and all that
kind of thing so it was complicated but
I think it just does when you're trying
to do something very subtle and you're
trying to see those changes develop as
you're making the film for me you have
to shoot in order i can't see another
way to do it you know and something will
come up in a scene Charlotte will do
something or Tom will do something or
something will appear in the moment that
you didn't expect and I want to be
shooting the next scene the next day so
I know what it is that we've done and I
always think that it's why for me a lot
of films that feels like a slight
disconnect as you go through the film
and I think it partly maybe because of
that and also the way my brain works I
just want to see it happen in order and
feel real to me so I can kind of you
know guide it as need to be now you said
you were scared to reach out to
Charlotte at first you know when she
finally signed on and time for that
matter were you intimidated about
working with them day to day not really
i mean the truth is i think any actor
did you know even if you've done have
much work you've done when you start a
new project it's a new project and i
think the thing that I realized to know
that first day on set we were all
nervous they were just as nervous as I
was you know and I think in many ways
that's really helpful like I think you
you bond in those beginning moments of a
film set and you know you kind of gang
together and you know
what I love about filmmaking is that you
you feel like a little team and it's let
you against the world and I think it's
very important that the actors are
brought into that process with you so
it's you and your crew and everybody
feels like you're in it together and
then there's nothing to be nervous about
because you know you mess up you mess up
and if you don't mess up you don't mess
up and you're there together doing it
together so I didn't I didn't wasn't
intimidating how do you get inside the
mind set of characters like this I mean
I'm not that age but I believed these
characters to be who they were on screen
how did you go about that did you talk
to any elders in your family did you
spend to an old person no I kind of very
early on I thought people kept saying
when I was coming up with the story they
were like how are you gonna do it you're
not an old person as if all people are
so different from younger people that
you know you can't relate to them but I
just didn't even think about it as I was
writing it's like I don't believe that
you changed that fundamentally I think
you know you did the core of who you is
you always probably set quite early on
in life anyway and so you you know you
keep like changing and evolving but your
key fears and emotions and doubts I
think stay the same so I try to write it
with that in mind how would I feel like
I felt huge amount of sympathy for both
of these characters I could understand
what both of them were feeling and going
through and you know why they would feel
kind of jealous and then you know
destroyed and I understand those things
so I didn't really worry about it and
then when i gave it to charlotte and Tom
they were just pleased that it was a
they felt like it felt truthful to their
experience of being their age and I
think it was that just scripts usually
in films about old people to seem to
forget that an old person is still
asking the big questions they're still
like trying to figure stuff out it's not
as if you get to the age of 15 night
well that's it everything's fine now the
end just wait for death like it's not
what happens so yeah I tried not to kind
of worry about it too much and you know
and films also tend to forget that you
know older people are also sexual people
their sexual beings they like to have
sex your film has a sex scene can you
talk about about that I mean did you
want to make a statement or were you
just now you just just I mean I think we
do
sex in relationships is incredibly
important and I think what sex is in a
relationship more than just having sex
is to reconnect with your partner in a
moment and said you know what I still
like you and you still like me and look
we still want to be together I think
that's what sex is so it plays a very
very important function and that doesn't
matter if it's like once a week or like
a once a year whatever it is it has an
important function and I think for these
two in this moment they really were
reaching out for each other they wanted
to reconnect and I think that you know
for me I think everything is so fragile
our understanding of everything and
ourselves and our relationships and I
think that in that moment when they have
sex if it had gone well it might have
been the end of the film like in many
respects they would have reconnected
they might have might have like lay down
i'm going to know what he might when I'm
sorry look I can't believe I'm not you
know thinking about how you're thinking
the situation she might and then what
I've talked but the sadness is for me
there's lots of moments in this when
they could nearly reconnect and they
can't in those moments because it's too
kind of complicated or painful or
whatever it is for both of them and they
were both finding the sex in fact the
sex scene for the actors Charlotte even
though she's done a lot of them doesn't
like them she's like why do I know of
course they don't like them Tom had
never done one and he was so excited it
was like his favorite day on set and he
was like he was like you know that
beating of his chest wasn't in the
script and he really just was so excited
and then he had you know I'd you know
the underpants were chosen we wanted him
to wear those Underpants and he was like
I should just take them off I should
just be naked here and I'm like we'll
see everything he's like that doesn't
matter you know I think you were gonna
have sex I should be naked and I'm like
no it's fine really keep them on and
Charlotte was like keep them all do not
want to see that